hello hello thank you coco um
very good to be here in los angeles i've
been traveling a lot but it's cool
because i've been in hot spots you know
like uh pittsburgh
kansas did you know there was a
pittsburgh in kansas no age or um
talaqua oklahoma which is how it's said
not taliqua like i originally said talaq
was a cherokee word talik was an
ex-girlfriend
whose mother's name is cherokee but the
thing is
i've been flying so much on 500 planes
in the last like couple years and the
more i fly the more i just don't like
the odds the more turbulence becomes the
sky's way of saying you do know you
shouldn't be up here right and you guys
remember sully sullenberger saved all
those people right now people don't
remember the details of the flight i do
us airways flight from new york to
charlotte north carolina and i know that
because a week before that flight went
down i bought a ticket on u.s airways
from new york to charlotte north
carolina to leave the day after that
flight went down so naturally when that
flight went down i was very upset that i
was not on the flight went down
why you ask why with the h in the front
that should be at the end of pittsburgh
i'll tell you
because everyone survived that crash and
you have a one in a million chance of
crashing if i was on that flight i would
have survived my one
and as we all know the count starts over
right guys
i want to add a little something i like
to call statistical immunity
now i assume a lot of you like me spend
a lot of your free time googling hate
groups you know
just to know where not to be in february
and um
i stumbled upon the website for the ku
klux klan they have a website and my
first thought was like finally wondering
when they were going to get with the
times
there's a part of me that loves that
they have a website because that means
that there was somebody who's like oh i
hate those who are different than me to
such an extent that i'm gonna learn
adobe flash
and what i really like about the website
besides the poetry section
was um
on the membership page there was a
phrase that caught my attention it said
the klu klux klan is not an equal
opportunity organization
you must meet our requirements 100 to
become a member
and i was like
who doesn't know that
who is the black dude that keeps showing
up to the parties
to where there's a klansman going like i
can't believe he's here again serve him
punch of course but change the website
it's 2011 you know the racial makeup of
this country is changing and i'm an
example of that because i am mixed race
i am biracial and i know you can't tell
by looking because i'm a consistent
shade
but um
it's true you know my mother was black
and my father was absent so i'm like
i'm half black half empty you know what
i'm talking about
wait wait half full i'm an optimist
thank you for laughing some of you just
got sad
some of you just went like now i know
why you need to tell jokes
don't do that people come up to me after
shows just concerned like do you miss
your father
i don't know what i would have done with
my dad do you miss him and i don't miss
what i've never had there's no
attachment no emotional significance it
would be the same to ask me if i missed
other things i've never had you know
just like do you miss your pterodactyl
wings
do you miss your superhuman ability to
rain kool-aid flavored crack
do you miss your self-integrity because
[Applause]
i'd rather have those three things
what's the dad gonna do throw football
i'd rather fly around making crackheads
happy
that sounds like a constructive weekend
thank you crackadactyl
and that's the story of kwanzaa thank
you very much i'm here on everybody
that's great thank you hey baron vaughn
really nice job thank you that's our
show